michael ruft heute beim arzt an
er ist krank und möchte einen arzttermin
machen so frau schnitt dann hatte ich
ihnen ihren termin noch mal
aufgeschrieben und ihr rezept bis
nächste woche das gleiche praxis dr
einen guten tag was kann ich für sie tun
hallo ich möchte einen termin machen
diese woche sieht es schlecht aus und
nächste aus es ist dabei akut
was haben sie denn mein bein mein bein
tut mir weh
ich kann überhaupt nicht mehr laufen ich
könnte jetzt gleich bei ihnen
vorbeikommen
nein mit was haben wir doch immer nur
bis mittags auf ich könnte ihnen in vier
wochen den donnerstagvormittag um 8 uhr
15 anbieten oder sind sie privat
versichert ja natürlich
ja dann kommen sie doch heute nachmittag
rein
ich dachte da haben sie geschlossen
ja für kassenpatienten
na ja ehrlich gesagt das war's ich bin
natürlich kasten platziert tja also dann
bleibt es doch bei donnerstag in vier
wochen
na gut das dann 815 war das ja ja genau
morgenstund hat gold im mund auf
wiederhören
ach auf wiederhören aber vergessen sie
bitte nicht ihre versicherungskarte
mitzubringen
das war unser video zum thema
arzttermine
michael ist das mit den arztterminen in
deutschland wirklich so schlimm
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich gar nicht ich
werde nie krank
achso und nie mehr was sagst du ja
manchmal muss man schon sehr lange
warten es kommt immer darauf an zu
welchem arzt man möchte und in welcher
stadt oder und in welcher stadt das
stimmt welche städte sind schlimm
großstädte hamburg ist furchtbar wenn
man einen arzttermin wahrhaben möchte
sonst ist hamburg schön berlin auch
jetzt wisst ihr bescheid wenn dir noch
übungen machen möchte zu diesem video
müsst ihr nicht so lange warten
ihr könnt einfach einen petschel werden
und hier könnt ihr sie german abonnieren
danke micha ich hoffe du wirst niemals
krank und viel spaß nina noch beim arzt
termine machen